these Farmers near New Delhi are worried
they say soaring temperatures are
damaging their produce and their
livelihoods India's in the grip of a
heat wave that's putting a burden on
those who can least afford it
we spend a lot of money on pesticides
and fertilizers but made no profits
we've worked hard but the crops still
failed because it's too hot
in April India's meteorological
Department issued several Heat Wave
warnings
they predicted above normal temperatures
for most of the country from that month
until June
but with nearly half of India's workers
being based Outdoors it's not just rural
areas that are affected
commuters in the cities have been doing
whatever they can to keep cool
it's too hot in Rajkot but because we
have to come out to work we've got cold
drinks to try to beat the heat the
temperatures around 40 to 45 degrees
Celsius right now
and experts say there'll be no relief in
the short term what is likely is that
once this
debens moves away eastwards
but the temperatures to start Rising
clear skies a lot of solar heating the
UN says more than 90 percent of India is
susceptible to extreme heat most people
here will have to do whatever they can
to get through the long hot days ahead
Paul King Al Jazeera